♪ ♪ ♪
- Stockholm, Fridays for Future,
mouvement des écoliers pour
le climat, devenu planétaire,
est né ici dans la capitale
suédoise.
(applaudissements)
- Greta, du är live nu.
- Oh! Hej!
- Greta Thunberg, son égérie,
n'est pas de la manifestation,
ou plutôt oui, mais sur écran
géant en direct de New York,
où elle s'apprête à assister
à la session extraordinaire
de l'ONU sur le climat.
(applaudissements)
En 13 mois à peine,
cette lycéenne de 16 ans
est devenue la Suédoise
la plus connue au monde.
(slogan)
Ces soeurs jumelles,
à peine plus âgées que Greta,
ont rejoint le mouvement
presque dès ses débuts.
Nous les rencontrons
à l'endroit même, devant
le parlement, où Greta Thunberg
a commencé en solitaire à faire
la grève pour le climat.
"Je crois que c'est une personne
extraordinaire et nous avons
besoin d'une figure de proue
pour que les gens sachent
qui nous sommes", dit Isabelle.
En même temps, on sent une sorte
d'agacement devant les questions
des journalistes qui n'ont
d'yeux que pour Greta.
Dans la société suédoise,
très égalitaire, on n'aime pas
trop les têtes qui dépassent.
"Je ne dirais pas qu'elle est
une leader, dit Sophia.
Elle serait plutôt un symbole
du mouvement, mais certainement
pas son leader car elle
ne décide pas pour nous."
Qui est véritablement
Greta Thunberg? Élevée par
une mère célèbre chanteuse
d'opéra et un père acteur,
avec une petite soeur atteinte,
comme elle, de syndrome
d'Asperger, elle souffre
également de trouble
obsessionnel compulsif.
Cette journaliste du quotidien
"Expressen", qui a nommé
Greta femme de l'année,
l'a rencontrée.
La jeune militante lui a confié
qu'être atteinte d'Asperger
donnait des super pouvoirs,
de concentration, entre autres.
"Elle m'a dit aussi qu'à
l'école, c'était difficile
parce qu'elle était différente,
dit-elle. Les élèves n'étaient
pas tous gentils, elle pleurait
tous les soirs, à la maison.
Et à l'école, elle se cachait
dans les toilettes.
Elle se sentait différente."
Les choses changent radicalement
quand Greta commence sa grève
pour le climat.
Dans cette école privée,
à une cinquantaine de kilomètres
de la capitale, qu'elle a
fréquentée l'an dernier,
elle rencontre Gabriella...
animatrice de sa propre chaîne
YouTube. Elles deviennent amies.
Gabriella fait son tout premier
podcast avec Greta, qui est
une inspiration, dit-elle.
"Parce qu'elle ne fait pas que
parler, elle agit!, s'exclame
la jeune animatrice.
Elle s'est assise, seule,
devant le Parlement.
Et elle est totalement fidèle
à elle-même dans tout ce
qu'elle dit et ce qu'elle fait."
Ce journaliste spécialisé
en environnement, qui a
rencontré Greta à quelques
reprises, avoue avoir pleuré
la première fois qu'il l'a
entendue devant un parterre
de politiciens de haut rang.
Et il n'était pas seul.
"Elle avait l'air si fragile,
si petite. On a tous été jeunes
et idéalistes, dit-il,
et on voulait changer le monde.
Mais nos professeurs,
nos parents ne nous écoutaient
pas." Selon lui, elle est
une véritable génie de
la communication.
"Et la façon dont elle le dit,
cette voix douce, mais
son message aux politiciens,
toujours aussi brutal."
Greta Thunberg n'a pas fini
de fasciner les Suédois.
Grâce à elle, le climat est
devenu le sujet numéro un
dans les préoccupations
de ses compatriotes.
Et un journal comme "Expressen",
qui l'a nommée femme de l'année,
consacre maintenant deux pages
quotidiennement au climat
et offre à ses 400 journalistes
des formations hebdomadaires
sur le réchauffement climatique.
Et puis, beaucoup de jeunes
ici souhaitent que "Grietta",
comme on dit en suédois,
devienne la plus jeune
récipiendaire du prix
qui porte le nom d'un autre
célèbre Suédois, le prix Nobel
de la paix.
Ici Alexandra Szacka, Radio-Canada, Stokholm